más de 1000 personas fallecidas por kobe
19 en los últimos cinco días es una
cifra que no sólo preocupa a portugal
sino que además lo sitúa como el país
con el mayor número de casos y número de
fallecidos por cada millón de habitantes
en el mundo en las últimas 24 horas se
registraron más de 200 personas muertas
por kobe 19 y más de 13.900 contagios la
situación en los hospitales es crítica
están trabajando prácticamente a su
máxima capacidad se han visto incluso
filas de ambulancias a las afueras de
los centros de salud a la espera para
poder ingresar a los pacientes y además
estos han sido trasladados desde el
centro hasta el interior del país para
intentar aliviar la situación en los
hospitales preocupa además al gobierno
en la propagación de esta nueva variante
de kobe 19 proveniente de reino unido y
ha sido ésta la principal razón por las
cuales han decidido cerrar todos los
centros educativos desde este viernes
por los próximos 15 días una medida que
podría extenderse el país se encuentra
en confinamiento con teletrabajo
obligatorio los comercios cerrados a
excepción de los que tienen que ver con
alimentación y farmacias y provisión de
circulación entre municipios los fines
de semana bajo este contexto se realizan
unas elecciones presidenciales este
domingo 24 enero y desde ya los sondeos
se apuntan a una alta abstención la
calcula en el 60 por ciento